as I'm sure you're aware 2020 is just
around the corner which means some
amazing new smartphones and their rumors
have already started to leak today we're
talking about the brand new Samsung S 11
and everything we know about it in 2019
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is David
Tomac and welcome back to the channel as
I've already mentioned today we're
talking about the up-and-coming Samsung
S 11 from what we know about it to date
there's actually some incredible tech
being tabled we might be seeing a whole
number of different things we've never
seen in smartphones but for the time
being we're actually still so unclear
what's gonna happen with this device we
even don't know if it's going to be
called the Samsung Galaxy S 11 or if
it's going to fall in line and go with
the consistency of the rest of the
Samsung's devices and then gonna upgrade
it and call it the Samsung S 20 what we
do know is that in February 2020 we're
gonna see this phone completely unveiled
and we're going to see all the tech
specs that we're talking about today
so what's rumored right now are some
pretty amazing things for the smart
phone if you're a smartphone fanatic
then you know that smartphones have kind
of been a little bit stale lately we've
been jumping from single to dual to
triple cameras but from innovation point
of view that's pretty much all we've
been getting and so far that's been okay
for most people to upgrade to the next
big thing but what's different this time
around in the Samsung S 11 and something
that's rumored today is an under the
glass front-facing camera now I don't
think I'd have to actually go out and
explain these to you guys too much but
that is a huge breakthrough in
technology to have a camera under the
glass completely hidden means no knotch
no bump no hole no nothing just glass
across the whole screen that means we're
moving closer and closer to a hundred
percent screen to body ratio like I said
this is still room attack but other
companies like Huawei are already
starting to implement them in their
up-and-coming flagships so potentially
Samsung may wait for this tech to mature
so that isn't any
any problems when they throw it in to
their 1500 $2,000 smartphone but we can
all have our fingers crossed and
hopefully we will see the under glass
front-facing camera in the Samsung S 11
besides from the front-facing camera
were also expected to see a huge spec
bump in the rear facing cameras
obviously we're going to get the three
cameras like we always do the normal the
telephoto and the wide-angle but what
we're actually rumored at the moment is
to see potentially the up-and-coming
stamp Singh 108 megapixel sensor now
this is a very very big rumor because at
the moment Samsung has patented and
released a 48 and a 64 megapixel sensor
which is more than likely gonna be in
the Samsung 11 but even with this jump
right now in the note 10 series we're
seeing a 12 megapixel sensor so
potentially we're going to be seeing
anywhere from i-5 to a ten times better
camera in the back of the Samsung S 11
if we get even the 48 megapixel sensor
I'm gonna be extremely happy because
that means all the photos are going to
come out crisp clear and potentially
we're going to be competing with the raw
photos of older DSLRs - the brand new
war photos of these flagship phones the
thing that throws me off with the 108
megapixel sensor besides from the fact
that it's a huge jump from the 12
megapixel in the note 10 is a simple
fact the Canon who is actually a very
reputable camera company and that's one
of their main focuses is the current
leader with 120 megapixel sensor so to
go from 120 megapixel sensor in a
full-frame dedicated camera and bring
down to a hundred and eight in a tiny
little camera in the back of a
smartphone personally I think that's too
big of a jump in 2020 and we might see
that somewhere around 2022 if not even
2020 or if Samsung however does come out
of nowhere and throw in this hundred and
eight megapixel sensor well that is
definitely going to be a game changer
for the whole smartphone industry we're
not going to be seeing youtubers
influencers photographers video
Cinematographers anything along the
swords carrying around big heavy dslr's
or even their smaller mirrorless
companions we might actually be seeing
them carrying around a smartphone 90% of
the time and then taking out the big
heavy cameras for paid projects staying
on the camera topic we're gonna be
seeing potentially a 5 times optical
zoom on the camera itself if not even
greater than that but what realistically
is gonna happen is we're gonna have the
5 times optical zoom and then like
Google pixel 4 does we're gonna have
amazing post digital zoom available from
the software itself I think the simple
fact that this s11 is rumored to keep
the wide-angle lens is more than enough
for most people to upgrade right now the
pixel for which only got released a
couple of weeks ago doesn't have a
wide-angle lens
it only has your standard and your
two-time telephoto google it came out
and announced this like the wide-angle
is no big deal at all and personally I
was quite hurt by that as I know a lot
of other youtubers were out there as
well not having a wide-angle lens is
something that's very critical to people
with smartphones working in tight places
mechs wise we're anticipating to see 12
gigabytes of RAM at an absolute minimum
on a flagship phone like this we're also
expected to see potentially the world's
first 5 nanometer chipset in the s11
alongside with the snapdragon 865 so if
we do get the snapdragon 865 it is one
of the most powerful chipsets in any
smartphone which means that it is going
to be able to annihilate every other
smartphone on the market right now in
2019 what we can also expect is the
simple fact that the headphone jack is
going to be completely removed samsung
started doing that for a recent while
now so going forward we're probably not
going to see the headphone jack
anymore and personally I'm okay with
that because I actually enjoy the audio
quality through a Bluetooth connection
more than I enjoy the quality from a
cheaper nastier headphone jack another
big thing that we're gonna see the
removal of in the Samsung Galaxy lineup
is the fact that the Bigsby button will
be removed completely removing the big
speed button is a big winner for samsung
here and for consumers I know personally
I use a Samsung Galaxy device and I keep
tapping that Bigsby button all the time
and it comes on I know you can block it
turn it off but it's still a very
inconvenient button to have and
something that really should never have
been there in the first place a new
feature that we won't actually see but
it will be very very useful is the
simple fact that they're gonna double
the size of the fingerprint scanner
underneath the glass you're not gonna be
how to tap around trying to locate that
fingerprint scanner so much anymore and
it's gonna make unlocking your phone
even easier than it already is last but
not least we're expecting to see
affordable prices especially with the 5g
models I don't know about the rest of
the world but in Australia the telcos
are taking advantage of 5g and they're
taking advantage of consumers Telstra
for example is one of Australia's
biggest telcos and right now if you go
on their website you'll see that in mid
next year they're gonna start charging
an additional $15 for consumers to use
the 5g network now personally I think
that's a bit unfair and a bit of a rot
but I guess there's not much you can do
about it when they're the leading 5g
telco supply in Australia they could
charge whatever they want and consumers
more than likely are going to pay the
fees personally I know that in Australia
there is way too much land to cover with
the 5g network and we're still
struggling to keep up with the 4G
network so I won't be converting to the
5g network in Australia for at least a
couple of years because realistically
there won't be any point the network
itself will be very small limited and
pocketed throughout Australia but if
you're not living in the hilar CBD you
might not be getting 5g for the next
five years that's all I have for you
guys
today about a samsung s 11 if you're
interested to find out more keep an eye
out for the codename Picasso
that's what Samsung has codenamed it
internally and hopefully we'll be seeing
a few more leaks between now and
February when it comes out if you
haven't already guys make sure you smash
that subscribe button
20-19 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday